alors il y a déjà ce que j'explique dans
le livre c'est que on est nous les êtres
humains des animaux on a tendance à
l'oublier mais du point de vue
biologique on est juste des singes on
est très proche des gorilles très
proches des chimpanzés par exemple d'un
point de vue de l'ADN les chimpanzés
sont plus proches de nous qui ne le sont
des gorilles donc on a vraiment une
feuille de papier entre nous et le monde
animal et parfois on oublie ça parce que
on a l'impression qu'on est les
meilleurs les plus intelligents les plus
forts alors qu'on y a une espèce qui est
très jeune très fragile les premières
traces de notre espèce ça remonte à peu
près à 300000 ans si on compare les
requins ils sont là depuis plus de 200
millions d'années donc on est une espèce
qui est très jeune et on a un gros
complexe de supériorité on a
l'impression d'être les plus intelligent
et en justifie l'exploitation des
animaux par ce complexe là donc j'essaie
de déconstruire tout ça et ça passe par
casser les idées reçues par exemple on a
l'impression qu'on est les seuls à avoir
de l'empathie pour les autres on est les
seuls à agir pour faire le bien et que
les animaux seraient pas capables de
différencier le bien du mal il y a plein
d'exemples dans ce livre notamment chez
les chimpanzés chez les éléphants ou il
y a des animaux qui agissent par
empathie sans
si tu parles des humains tu as raison de
dire ça comme ça chien
pour les souris Cyril parce que à mon
avis les chats domestiques contre des
rats je crois je donne pas cher de la
peau du chat avec brassard sécurité
[Applaudissements]
de 13 de 2 secondes sur les animaux
maintenant
est-ce que vous savez comment on
apprécie souvent une personne a un
animal vous par exemple j'avais lu c'est
le gorille parce que vous êtes fort
comme cet homme voilà vous êtes clinique
vous êtes besoin de dominé vous allez
relativement peu de vocabulaire vous
êtes le bourrin non mais c'est vrai
enfin tout ça
on voit à quel animal
quoi
qui récolte charognard où y'avait mais
c'est vrai que c'est fou
un animal qui parle pas
en fait qu'à cette histoire j'ai même
pas pensé à le faire non ça j'ai pas
pensé à Castaldi c'est pas grave je me
porte très bien
oh ça va ça va ça va c'est bon ça va non
mais c'est à traiter le bourrin comme
truc
tu peux dire le truc intelligent
maintenant
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
Gilles moi je vais vous poser une
question est-ce que tous les animaux
pour vous sont les égaux des hommes si
on prend une fourmi un animal qui nous
voilà qu'on n'aime pas
justement parler des frelons par exemple
est-ce qu'on est tous
la notion d'égalité ça a pas de sens
parce qu'on est tous des espèces
différentes avec nos propres
spécificités nos capacités cognitives on
est très différent donc faire une
hiérarchie ou essayer de faire une
égalité ça n'a pas de sens par contre la
différence ça doit pas nous inciter à
l'irrespect et à l'exploitation c'est
pas parce que une espèce est différente
de nous n'a pas les mêmes capacités
cognitives que nous qu'on peut se
permettre de la détruire de lui faire du
mal etc et puis surtout on juge les
autres espaces à travers nos yeux nous
humains on prend les critères qui nous
arrangent pour faire la hiérarchie par
exemple on dit on est les plus
intelligents parce qu'on fait des fusées
bon on est les plus intelligents parce
qu'on fait des bombes nucléaires
effectivement on est les seuls à le
faire est-ce que c'est une preuve
d'intelligence ou au contraire
est-ce que ça peut être une preuve de
manque d'intelligence parce qu'on est la
seule espèce à pouvoir s'autodétruire à
ce point et si on regarde au niveau de
l'évolution c'est quoi être intelligent
pour les scientifiques c'est survivre au
fil des millénaires et arriver à durée
dans le temps et nous pour l'instant si
on prend ce critère là Michel Drucker
seulement on n'est pas les plus
intelligents mais on risque de nous
pousser nous-mêmes vers l'extinction
non j'ai une question pour de Guillaume
Jonson qui fait souvent des décès très
intelligentes mais un jour dans cette
émission il a dit parce que c'est un peu
énervé si je dois sauver mon chien mon
chiot que j'aime ou un enfant que je ne
connais pas dans un incendie je prends
le chien que j'aime parce que c'est
c'est mon chien est-ce que je vais te
poser la question est-ce que pour vous
malgré tout l'être humain reste
supérieur alors supérieur non mais moi
c'est pas le choix que que je ferais
j'aime beaucoup ma chaîne et je l'adore
mais si je devais sauver ma chienne ou
un enfant que je connais pas je
choisirai de choses de sauver l'enfant
j'essaierai de faire les deux dans la
mesure du possible mais je choisirai
l'enfant c'est pas parce qu'on estime
que notre espace n'est pas supérieur
qu'on n'accorde pas une importance
prioritaire à notre espèce tous les
animaux font ça une vache va faire
passer son veau avant le fermier
n'importe quel animal va d'abord
protéger les siens et ses congénère donc
c'est une attitude naturelle de faire ça
mais ça veut pas dire qu'on est
supérieur ça veut dire qu'on est
différent voilà toi on est resté trois
quarts d'heure
en défense son espace en fait la raison
non mais quand on dit que les animaux
sont les seuls qui ont la conscience de
mourir les humains pardon sont des sols
qui ont la conscience de mourir non pas
du tout il y a plein d'animaux qui ont
conscience d'eux-mêmes et qui ont
conscience de la mort et du temps qui
passe par exemple les orangs-outans sont
capables de planifier leur trajet dans
le futur de prévoir un trajet à l'avance
et donc ce qui suppose d'avoir une
connaissance de l'espace une
connaissance du temps il y a plein
d'espèces d'oiseaux qui cachent de la
nourriture à certains endroits et qui
viennent la rechercher des années des
mois ou des années plus tard donc ça
veut dire qu'il se rappelle où ils l'ont
mis donc ça suppose de se représenter
l'environnement et ils ont conscience du
temps puisque caché pour plus tard ça
veut dire qu'on a conscience que le
temps avance